- [Crystal] I feel like I was dehydrated.
Okay.
- [Interviewer] Crystal?
- [Crystal] Yes?
- [Interviewer] Crystal,
where are you from originally,
where'd you grew up?
- I grew up in two different places
like Violet Hill, Arkansas
and I grew up in Beaverton, Michigan.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and
how was your childhood?
Did you grow up with both your parents?
- No,
my father was...
I found him when I was three,
hanging from our basement rafters
but my mom and I had a stepdad who was
60 years older than me;
he was in World War II, so...
- [Interviewer] So your dad hung himself?
- Yeah, he had mental issues
and they put him in a psych ward,
and then a week later he was...
He wasn't supposed to get out
and the doctors let him out
and he took a whole bottle
of Librium, I think it was,
and he hung himself.
Yeah, and the suicide note
was a week before that,
you know, I don't know.
I don't really remember much.
I do remember pushing his
dead body a little bit,
so I have PTSD from that, but...
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was about three and a half.
I'm 36 now.
So I mean, it never
really bothered me though.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood
with your stepdad and your mom?
- Honestly, I think I had
the most beautiful childhood
anybody could ever have.
I was very fortunate.
I grew up
at least on 80 acres; we ran a horse farm
and you know I had nothing
but nature and animals.
- [Interviewer] It was
in Arkansas or Michigan?
- Both.
Arkansas was more prettier.
That was a rural area.
Violet Hill, Arkansas was like
there was a school, a post office,
convenience store.
And my driveway was two miles long
dirt road.
It was just, it was so pretty.
And then
yeah, I miss that place.
- [Interviewer] And then
where'd your life go
when you left home?
What age did you leave home?
- I left home at 16.
My stepdad had died and
then my mom moved in
her current husband, which is Tom,
and we didn't get along.
He was really not my friend.
And so that was a messy move-out
so I couldn't be there anymore.
So at 16, I moved out with my kids' dad,
my first two kids' dad,
and that was quite interesting.
He worked all the time
and I got to stay home.
- [Interviewer] So you have how many kids?
- All together, I have four kids.
- [Interviewer] Did you raise all four?
- No.
My first two were with me
until my oldest son was six,
my daughter was three,
and then Levi...
He's still was his dad and family.
And then my youngest son,
he's three and a half now, four...
He was born two months early
and he is with the father's daughter,
which isn't his blood daughter
but pretty much his daughter.
- [Interviewer] And so you're
living here on the street now?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're in a tent?
- No.
No.
I live in the racks
and I live in like kind of a bird's nest.
I don't really want to live in a tent.
I can't be city-bound
like this really bad.
I go up to like, I think it's...
If you know where chats
chat or what is it?
I'm not really even from
here, I'm from Michigan
and me and my boyfriend came
down here but, it's a park.
- [Interviewer] How long
you been in Skid Row?
- A month, month and a half.
- [Interviewer] Oh, that's it?
- Yeah.
It's different.
- [Interviewer] What's your drug?
- I like...
I prefer black, as they call it;
heroin but...
I mean, I do both but
I don't like that ice.
It makes me real sick.
- [Interviewer] You do
both heroin and what else?
- Ice.
And I smoke weed.
- [Interviewer] Ice is...
Cocaine?
- They call it clear.
Meth.
- [Interviewer] Crystal meth?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
And what do you do for money?
What a lot of girls do?
- No.
I dumpster-dive.
Like the other day I pulled
a canopy out of a dumpster
and I got like 150 for that.
I found a convertible thing.
That was 150.
Or, you know,
you go over to Walgreens
and you stand there
and people will just hand you money
or items I'll just trade, you know...
or I'll call my mom.
That's once a month, so...
Can I put this out somewhere?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you can
just put it out on the floor.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Did you
ever talk to your kids?
- Not really.
My first two kids...
My mom and their dad...
That's a really rough situation.
My first two kids' dad, I
was with him for 11 years.
So I was 16 til I was 27
and those two kids were my life, like...
Nobody helped me, the dad wasn't there
and me and my son
we bonded really good,
but my mom kind of took my kids over
when I lost my apartment
because I was cooking meth really bad
and she was like sending me out the door,
you know what I mean?
So it's been about 10 years
since I seen my first two kids
and then Eli
he was in Kalamazoo and I
was running around Kalamazoo.
And the little one I never see.
I adopted him out.
It's just hard for me to see him.
His dad was just murdered
while I was in jail.
Bludgeoned to death by a baseball bat.
So yeah,
that was rough.
- [Interviewer] So you
were in jail for what?
- I was in jail this last time...
I took drug court,
which in Michigan...
In Michigan, meth is a felony
and I had possession of meth pop up
and then I took awhile, that one.
And before that I had
got a possession of meth
and a (muffled) charge so I
was facing all three of those
and a marijuana charge.
So I took drug court, which
is like an 18-month program.
And well, I knew that wasn't going to work
so I went through the loops with that,
got caught and then they
took me off drug court
and gave me nine months.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever have contact
with your mom and stepdad?
- My stepdad died when I was like,
before I moved out or,
it was after we moved to Mount
Pleasant, but he died 97.
And then my mom,
we talk but me and my mom aren't close.
I mean, she was sleeping
with my first kids' dad
and I didn't find that out til later
but she's just been really kind of rotten
and she doesn't even let me see my kid.
She has Bella and then
Caleb is with his dad
but those two are...
It's hard for me to talk to her
when she would bring my kids down
and go to the Christmas party
at my aunt's house, you know,
five miles away
and she couldn't even bring
them over to see me, you know?
So I don't think my daughter
even knows who I am really.
I mean, she knows who I am, but
we don't really talk at all.
It's hard.
My mom's just, she hurts me a lot.
- [Interviewer] And your
boyfriend now is a good guy?
- He's a good guy.
I guess we're going
through some tough times.
I have been with him since June.
What about him is we
have the same birthday.
It's weird.
I'm a few hours earlier.
He is a good guy, but he's kinda...
He's from Kalamazoo
and people from Kalamazoo
don't usually come out.
The only reason I'm here is 'cause of him.
I never wanted to come to California.
He wanted to get high under a bridge.
The lead singer of Red Hot
Chili Peppers or something
sings Under the Bridge
and he wants to go under a
bridge and OD or something.
I don't know.
And also he was facing
some felony charges.
So, you know...
He just got done doing
five years in prison.
So I got my friend to drive
us out here and drop us off
but he was supposed to be
working and stuff, you know
and that guy didn't come through.
So we got stuck in the street.
- [Interviewer] So where do you suppose
your life will go from here?
- I don't know.
Honestly, right now I
think about death a lot.
It seems like it would
just be a lot easier
'cause I just get tired of it.
I've been in the street a good six years.
And when I say in the streets,
I don't just go sleep in people's houses.
I'm not your average girl.
I don't mingle with men.
You know what I mean?
I usually just stay to my partner, but...
if there's any help me
and my boyfriend Blake
would like to get clean together.
I feel like that's the
only way that I'm (muffled)
is if somebody is doing it with me.
It's hard for me because
I mean, I've always been on...
I started shooting up drugs
when I was nine, or no 12,
but I started smoking weed
and stuff when I was nine
but I did start shooting up cocaine at 12.
So I've been a drug addict
for quite a long time.
- [Interviewer] You told me
your childhood was perfect.
- Yeah, that was pretty.
Yeah, but I was curious.
At 12, my mom...
The internet was out
and my mom never really watched me.
My childhood wasn't perfect,
but it was very nice.
I mean, I always had room
to run and animals play with
but I never had any friends.
I was very, very isolated
and I really didn't have no friends.
But at 12,
yeah, I got on the internet.
I was meeting guys off the internet at 12.
I really started going downhill at 12
and my mom didn't really care
and my stepdad, you know,
he was there.
So yeah, I started using.
- [Interviewer] Where'd
you get introduced to drugs
at that young age?
- Well,
it wasn't hard.
I always hung out with older people;
when I was in middle school,
I was having high schoolers
pick me up to go party.
My best friend was in high school
so I kind of always hung
out with older people.
I guess I never really
fit in with my crew.
- [Interviewer] And you
left home at an early age?
- Yeah.
- Is this
because you didn't get along with stepdad?
- Yeah, he was really weird, and...
He kinda moved in and it was uncomfortable
because my mom was like,
"Oh, you're just jealous,"
and maybe I was, I mean...
My mom was all I had, you know,
besides my grandma and I don't
know, he just was like...
Took over and was mean
and try to, she's like,
"You're just jealous because
I spend more time with him,"
and she was drinking and it was just...
I didn't want to be there anymore.
He made me feel really weird.
And I had a boyfriend
at the time that worked
and we got our own place,
- [Interviewer] You say he
made you feel really weird.
- Yeah, he would make
comments all the time.
I almost think that...
And I don't like the fact
that my daughter's with him
but I almost think maybe
he was mad because I wouldn't, you know,
acknowledge his...
I don't know.
He was just a weird guy in general.
I really don't like the guy now.
He really messed up my whole relationship
with my children and my mom.
She won't even talk to me
on the phone because of him.
And, you know, I just...
He hates me or something, I don't know.
He tells my kids all
kinds of lies about me.
And I don't know.
I really don't like the guy.
If he died tomorrow...
I really don't have nothing for that man.
I really don't like him at all, actually.
I haven't been able to go home.
I haven't been able to
step foot on the property.
He's made my life hell.
So, yeah...
- [Interviewer] All right,
Crystal, well thank you so much
for talking to me.
- Yes, thank you.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with everything.
- Thank you.
Appreciate it.